I hate intros nanatsu no taizai season 2
part 2 side no if you're looking for
part one you can find in the description
episode 13 we hop back into it with
Elaine acting sporadically and attacking
both ban and Jericho ban is able to calm
her down a bit and says that he can
accept her even like this if it means
that they can be together this makes her
happy but now that there is no rage to
feed the resurrection spell cast by the
commandments she goes back to being dead
too of the commandments molestia and
gallant appear to attack van ben uses
his ability to SAP their strength away
adding it to his own making him just as
powerful and starts working over Galan
moleska forces band soul from his body
and Galan eats it or so they thought but
zhu bajie Oh had showed up and used his
soul as a decoy so he was eaten by
gallon instead this allows ban to make
it back to his body and escape with
Jericho and Alain we then get a look at
fraud rune who is still inhabiting
dreyfuses body
he ends up getting captured by the
polite ease of the azure sky after one
of their members del jury puts him under
a charm spell episode 14 Jericho is
forced into the carry role as the
lateness somehow retaining life but not
enough to walk and man is exhausted from
fighting to makes it into a cave where
she finds a mysterious bar and also the
last sin s kannur who hides them gallon
and malesko a show up looking for them
but ended up getting plastered instead
after gallon gets drunk he's in a good
mood so he decides to let all of them
live if eskimo working beat him in a
fight to the death where they take turns
hitting each other as the game gets
underway Merlyn consents Eskin oars
power with his overall being at over
50,000 and rising del and sees that he
will lose so he tries to run but the
commandments curse is applied to the ten
commandments as well so since he lied
about finishing the game Galan is turned
to stone mullet school event tries to
extract an e Eskin or salt but that
doesn't go so well and she bursts into
flames while being defeated s Canora is
proved to be really strong but only
during the day so when night rolls
around he's back to being scrawny and in
the last scene King shows up and is
reunited with a lame episode 15 fraud
awaits that bound and talks with polite
ease of the azure skies captain Denzel
who is king vultures younger brother he
is able to break free and has
little skirmish with Denzel Danis still
doesn't have her memory so she's
learning to dance her Matrona who we
also learned has a family now miss
injure birds appear all over the land
dropping an invitation to the vies
Delphi festival where the winners wish
will be granted Millie Otis and the
others realized it's probably you trapa
they're gonna go anyways one of the
birds attacks and injures madronas kids
so she wants to go to the fight festival
to make sure it doesn't happen again
back over to progerin whose fight gets
interrupted by grey road and both sides
decide to fight another time for fraud
Hren goes he tells him that he is more
of a replacement in the commandments and
the real member is actually go through
the episode 16 black Sidious sets up
obstacles to stop the week from making
it to the fight festival so everybody
gets caught up in a massive maze Dani
was separated from Matrona but is found
by Elisabeth and Hawk who helped her
even though she doesn't remember them
the three of them then reunite with Gil
Thunder and Hauser
well fighting with some of the mazes
creatures Hawk realizes his new power
when he eats a creature with magical
abilities he then gains that ability so
basically he's like a budget Kirby the
rest of the episode is pretty filler ask
so basically everybody makes it through
the maze II episode 17 once everybody
makes it to clock see me and roll we
learned that gloxinia is actually the
first fairy king as for the festival in
the first round contestants will fight
in pairs and in order to win the match
you have to either kill or neutralize
the opponent Elena and Elisabeth go up
against Torah and jiggy Moe and Elaine
solos em both Ben and Mellie Otis go up
against dolls oink alzo accidentally
killing them while arguing about who the
best waifu is the other matches aren't
so straightforward with king indiana
going up against the troll gone and
gloxinia servant ii episode 18 it starts
out as a close fight but king uses all
of his power again like at the forest to
defeat gloxinia servant now he's too
weak to fight so it's up to deanna she
summons some stone versions of the gang
who defeat the drool doll I'm winning
the match moving on to the next match
between Gotha and Jericho against Hawk
and Eskin or we take a quick detour to
learn that Camelot has fallen to Zell
juries and has become a haven for the
demons back to the fight go there
decides to go all-out even striking his
partner Jericho down for trying to stop
he attacks s Kannur with a mental attack
putting him in a nightmare this kind of
backfires as s Kannur sees a Sun in his
mind which procs his transformation
although he is in at full power they're
both launched powerful attacks but Gotha
is left standing afterwards winning the
match episode 19 the reason go thir was
still standing is because s kannur had
targeted gloxinia and role instead
dealing major damage mili artiss goes to
fight withdrawal and gloxinia while the
others get captured by giant rock hands
one of the contestants Gil Frost gets
everyone to safety by teleporting them
to Leona's but he's exhausted afterwards
meliodas is left to fight by himself and
still wins the 1v2 but then all of the
ten commandments show up he tries to
hold his own but it's severely
outmatched
after taking a beating he tries to use
his revenge counter that he defeated
Hendrickson with in season 1 but esta
rosa steps in and stops him yep Azote
wenting it's revealed that Mellie Otis
had abandoned his role as the leader of
the ten commandments and is responsible
for the war 3,000 years ago Luis Scola
tries to eat his soul but ban is
teleported back and destroys all of her
horse before she can
despite bands best efforts to stop
Esther Jose he goes on to stab through
all seven of Meli Otis's hearts killing
him upon seeing this elisabeth requests
to be sent back as well where she finds
Mele Otis's pinkish and body we then
jump ahead a bit to Elisabeth healing
Matrona skids
Arthur and others are still fighting
against the invading demons Luther had
been imprisoned with his allegiances in
question jump on over to ruin and
freesia from season 1 who have their
souls eaten by froderick gugus is alive
as well and he winds up at the boar hat
where elizabeth is at episode 21
Googie has a nasty meal prepared by
elizabeth and then dips we then see that
Mellie Otis's body is being kept safe at
the boar Hat with Elizabeth soon after
Gogi is least the former chief holy
night Sarah trust that's been presumed
dead for 10 years shows up at the bar he
was brought back from the dead by
moleska last spell as well after seeing
that Mellie Otis is dead ser tres uses a
spell to enter his memories
Elizabeth do you go back to Donna far
right after Liz had died and melly Otis
lost control of his emotions destroying
the city meliodas comes walking out of
the destroyed city with the reincarnated
Liz or Elizabeth as a baby the king had
a premonition about Elizabeth so he
adopts her into his family Millie Otis
was okay with this as long as he could
be her personal guard however she
doesn't remember knowing him as a child
so this is news to her jump back to the
present and over to Mellie Otis who is
now in purgatory he talks with the demon
king that apparently cursed him so that
he can't die every time le Otis had died
the demon king was stripping away some
of his emotions he tells Mellie Otis to
feed on his emotions and he'll regain
his forgotten strength in the last scene
we see that Leonys is under siege by the
demons and Eskin or scores of defy
Testarossa ii episode 22 as stir osa can
use full counter to block physical
attacks and has darkness magic to
counter Eskin or son attacks so he
thinks he has the advantage turns out
not to be the case as ESCA Norse power
continues to ramp up and he sends Esther
oza and Zelda Roos flying over the
horizon with his last attack to fly it
against the other commandments Denzel
sacrifices himself to manifest Nera
basta a goddess into his body probably
wasn't the play because she is
immediately killed by derrière II
Elizabeth and Sara trashed start heading
towards Leonys after hearing gets under
attack they are greeted by monks bee and
derriere II who seem to recognize
Elizabeth where derriere he goes to
kills Eris Elizabeth uses arc which is
an ability that the goddess Mara basta
had used before she was defeated in the
last scene meliodas wakes up and makes
his heroic return deterring their
attacks episode 23 their harry acts as a
distraction while montz p tries to use
all of his magical power to surprise and
kill Mellie Otis Millie Otis is able to
get off his full counter blessing months
P and airy area way over to the side
characters eel and Jericho are put into
egg things and the others try and get
them free if they break the eggs the
people inside turn into demons and if
you kill in the presence of grey road
you lose the rest of your life span
gnorga doe doesn't know this and kills
one of the demon spawn losing his
life as well Gil Frost was actually
Vivian in disguise who teleports guilt
under away because she's in love with
him Jericho's older brother Gustav
stunts the transformation by freezing
the eggs saving his little sister's life
before losing his own bisque used the
entrance of Merlin who makes her
reappearance back in her body she is
able to kill in the presence of gray
road because she casts a spell on
herself to make her remaining time alive
to be infinite until she decides
otherwise she has been alive so long
that nobody knew she is the daughter of
beli Lewin we don't know who that is but
the commandments sure do and are shook
by it she goes on to destroy the castle
while capturing gray road in a test tube
Hendrickson and Zahra truss begin to
fight with rogering zero Trask uses the
last of his life force to purge fraud
ran from dreyfuses body this is when
Melly Otis shows up to fight with
progerin and his overall is sitting at
60,000 now but he seems a little bit
more sinister episode 24 progerin is
clearly gonna lose so he plans to
self-destruct and destroy the kingdom
chilled grimoire shows up and convinces
him not to so instead he requests that
Melly Otis kills him since Melly Otis
has given off a bit of an evil vibe
right now he is happy to oblige
Merlin explains to everybody that Melly
Otis has died many times and is
resurrected by the curse that the demon
king had put on him now his personality
has started to regress to what it was
when he was the most wicked of demons
Millie Otis is conflicted because he
doesn't want to become evil but he needs
the power to protect Elizabeth the next
day the kingdom of Leonys is repaired
thanks to Merlin and child granny more
is returned to normal after Veronica
kisses in the flight isn't over yet
though with many of the holy Knights and
city folk that were brainwashed by one
of the commandments bling to the South
since Elaine is still alive malesko 'la
is presumed to be alive as well but it's
not just her childress gloxinia droll
and esta rosa are also still out there
we get a quick look at Jericho who
develops ice power similar to her
brothers Gotha is released as well but
it still isn't entirely clear where his
allegiances lie I'm gonna be doing the
future seasons and that'll be in the
bottom-left it whenever I'm finished
with it or you can check out all the
nanatsu no taizai recaps in this
playlist here you can also find the
links in the description below and the
only thing I hate more than intros is
out
rose